showdown in berlin so santschi gegen
bürgermeister michael müller beide
wollen im bundestag und kämpfen um den
selben wahlkreis fairer wettkampf oder
haben frauen ist schwerer karriere in
der politik zu machen
nur knapp ein drittel der
bundestagsabgeordneten sind frauen hilft
eine quote oder soll nur die kompetenz
entscheiden und es sind kinder häufig
das karriereende für frauen ganz viele
themen wo ich jetzt schon pulls up von
210 der sion nicht beruhigen wird
wo fange ich jetzt also genau ich stelle
mir das wie folgt vor du willst
kandidieren für den bundestag dann kommt
ein steinernes netz rein und macht da
jetzt irgendwie auch mit motiviert dich
das oder macht sich das sauer ganz
ehrlich nein darum geht gar nicht weder
motivation noch sein sondern ich komme
aus einer region meine eltern kommen aus
einer region wo ich wahrscheinlich wenig
kandidierte im knast säße ich finde wir
leben in einem demokratischen land wo
ist total normal sein sollte in einem
wahlkreis zu kandidieren der auch mein
heimatbezirk ist genauso wie er
der regierende das recht hat in dem
wahlkreis auch anzutreten
für mich ist das echten demokratischer
prozess ich bin total stolz
irgendwie in diesem land zu leben und
das machen zu können ohne dafür
repression oder so zu erfahren als dass
ich mal so es ist eher die seite dass es
sich dann doch irgendwo motiviert oder
oder glücklich stellt das macht sich
nicht sauer die konfrontation dann aber
ich habe schon letztes jahr kommuniziert
ganz offen und transparent dass ich mich
bewerben werde um diesen wahlkreis haben
daher
ich bin bei meiner linie geblieben und
bin mit mir im reinen jetzt ist eine
blöde konstellation entstanden
aber ich glaube das muss möglich sein
einem fairen transparenten wettstreit
dass der beste die beste dann gewinnt ja
auch so was meinst du wieder denkt er
auch so ich glaube also wir können beide
nur gewinnen wenn wir beide genauso
denken weil wenn wir es nicht hätten
wenn es unfair würde und intransparent
unglaublich schade dass der parteien
[Musik]